this videos made possible by brilliant
you're gonna learn more about brilliant
later in today's video but if you'd like
to learn more around the right now you
go to brilliant a dork forward slash by
graphics you'll also find a link in the
description below he was the most
influential thinker in world history a
man whose ideas permeated every sector
of society here's the father of modern
logic the inventor of the science of
biology and the founder of ethical
reasoning despite only a small fragment
of his writing surviving to our times
his influence on both the Western and
the Islamic world has been profound
in this week's by graphics we discover
the brilliance of Aristotle
[Music]
the details of aristotle's life are
sketchy
we know that he was born in 384 BCE in
the greek-macedonian town of Styria on
the north coast of the Aegean Sea
his father nikka Marcus was the court
physician to the Macedonian King Amon
insist the seconds it is believed that
Aristotle's mother faced us was
descended from Greek aristocracy the
couple had three children with Aristotle
being the youngest he had a sister named
Aaron Nestor and a brother named Aaron
Estes nikka Marcus died when aristotle
was only 13 his mother died soon after
and he was raised through his teenage
years by his older sister's husband
Proximus by the age of 17 aristotle II
was sent to Athens to pursue higher
education there he enrolled at Plato's
Academy Plato was the most renowned
thinker of the time who himself had been
taught by the great Socrates the Academy
had been founded 20 years earlier and
was situated beside an olive grove
outside of the city walls rather than a
formal school with a set curriculum and
a clear delineation between teacher and
students the Academy provided an
informal setting where the master Plato
would pose problems to be pondered by
his students instead of listening to
lectures the students were encouraged to
engage in dialectic discussion in order
to establish a truth by means of
reasoned argument the main subjects
under discussion were philosophy
mathematics and astronomy aristotle
studied at the academy for 20 years
advancing from students to teacher
during this time he developed a great
respect and a close friendship with
Plato the two men however they did have
some fundamental philosophical
differences as a result when Plato died
in 347 BCE Aristotle his most brilliant
student was not offered the directorship
of the Academy that privilege instead
went to Plato's nephew spew Sufis
shortly thereafter Aristotle left the
Academy apparently unhappy with the
direction that it was taking it is also
possible that he was keen to get out of
Athens as a result of the tide of anti
Macedonian sentiment in the city
Aristotle had by this time developed
some important friendships which would
pave the way forward for him one of them
was hummus king of the Greek city of our
tenías in Asia Minor hummus was a former
student at Plato's Academy upon hearing
of the Masters death he invited
Aristotle to come to our tenías
Aristotle settled in Asus the city which
faced the island of Lesbos there he
became the head of a group of
philosophers establishing a brand new
Academy his focus there was on the
observation of the natural world he also
began to work on two volumes dealing
with politics and kingship during his
time in our source Aristotle met fell in
love with and married the niece of
Hermia's named fie theists soon a
daughter was born who was also named a
theist
soon after a source was attacked by the
Persians and King Hermia's was taken
captive and executed Aristotle and his
family they relocated to the island of
Lesbos where they spent the next two
years it was here that he indulged in
his passion for the study of marine life
the work that Aristotle conducted on the
islands gave rise to a whole new
scientific discipline biology the study
of life he was relentlessly systematic
in his classifications creatures they
were divided into larger groups
according to their characteristics this
resulted in the publication of three
books that minutely detail the
characteristics of living things he also
studied the ecology of the island
in 343 BCE Aristotle received an
invitation from philip ii the king of
Macedon to come and tutor his son
Alexander who was 13 at the time
Aristotle accepted and moved his family
to Macedonia where he became the
director of the Royal Academy King
Philip had a reputation as an uncouth
and uneducated barbarian warrior he was
prouder that his son was developing the
same strength of resolve but wanted the
prince to balance his strength with
knowledge and with wisdom and he feared
that the instruction that was being
provided by the boys tutors would only
create another version of himself it was
these concerns that prompted the king to
call for the great teacher
Aristotle at the academy Aristotle
taught Alexander and other young members
of the royal household in a style
reminiscent of the Platonic Academy he
instructed them in morality in logic as
well as the arts and medicine in
addition one-on-one lessons were given
to Alexander the Roy was impetuous and
stubborn often challenging and resisting
his teacher
however Aristotle exhibited a great
patience as he shaped and molded the
thinking of the future conqueror his
superior reasoning inevitably won over
the prince one of Aristotle's greatest
challenges was to reign in Alexander's
impetuous nature in one memorable
exchange he asked the prince what the
most valuable virtue was that a soldier
could possess Alexander immediately
replied that it was courage but what
Aristotle asked would happen if the
warriors excess couraged caused him to
run ahead of his army and face the enemy
all alone Alexander acknowledged that he
would surely be killed what though the
teacher asked would happen if a lack of
courage caused the soldier to run the
other direction well then he would be a
coward chaotic scientist reply by this
exchange Aristotle taught Alexander the
importance of always finding the middle
points and therefore developing balance
in one's life Aristotle also educated
Alexander in the warrior hero traditions
of the past
he provided the teenager with a copy of
the Iliad and encouraged him upon
assuming rulership so conquer the
barbarian lands to the east Aristotle
has a very ethnocentric view of non
Greeks which he earned out
they passed on to his people he viewed
them as fit only for slavery and
famously gave this piece of advice to
the future Conqueror be a leader to the
Greeks and a despot to the barbarians to
look after the former as friends and
relatives and to deal with the latter as
with beasts or plants Aristotle was able
to cultivate in the teenage prince love
of reading and of a learning for the
rest of his life
Alexander remained an avid reader
developing a special love for the
writings of Homer it is claimed that he
learned all 15,000 693 lines of poetry
in the Iliad by heart
the princes education at the hands of
the great philosopher it came to an
abrupt halt in 340 BC Alexander was the
16 year old heir to the throne and he
was called to Pella to rule over
Macedonia while his father was off
waging war by 335 BCE Alexander had
succeeded his father as king one of his
first acts was to conquer Athens which
paved the way of her Aristotle to return
to the city where he had spent his
formative years Plato's Academy which
was now run by a former student names
and ah Critias was still the leading
influence on creeks thinking
however Aristotle was given permission
by Alexander to start up his own rival
Academy as a foreigner Aristotle was not
able to own property in Athens as a
result he rented a building called the
Lyceum which was a former wrestling
school now outside of the city
unlike Plato's Academy the Lyceum was
not a private club for half of the Daris
Dawson and his tutors would teach their
paying students in advanced topics and
the doors would be opened and the
lectures and discussion would be free of
charge and open to anyone who wished to
attend Aristotle spent the bulk of the
remainder of his life working at the
Lyceum he developed a unique style
teaching his students while they
wandered around the gardens of the
school this gave rise to the nickname
peripatetic s' meaning people who wander
about the scope of study at the Lyceum
was vast
Aristotle wanted his students to
research and write about every area of
human thought from mathematics to
biology philosophy politics and rhetoric
students were required to ride their
arguments down in manuscript form these
were collected in the Lyceum's library
which became one of the first great
collections
of historical writings at some time
during the first few years after his
return to Athens Aristotle's wife
atheists she died it is believed that
the Persian King upset that Aristotle
had helped to arrange an alliance with
NASA donea had paisius arrested and then
executed Aristotle he was heartbroken in
his grief he raped the only poem of his
life that survived which he titled an
ode to virtue in time though Aristotle
he became romantically involved with a
woman named her Phyllis some account
states that her Phyllis was a slave who
had been given to Aristotle by the court
of Alexander but this cannot be verified
the two were never married but her
Phyllis bore Aristotle many children the
first of whom they named Nick amicus
after Aristotle's father her Phyllis
remains with Aristotle until his death
during the years that Aristotle
established his Lyceum at Athens his
former pupil Alexander was very busy
conquering the known world as his power
grew so did his ego the virtues that the
Philosopher's had instilled in him were
cast aside as he became increasingly
megalomaniacal
eventually he proclaimed himself to be
divine and required that all peoples
prostrate themselves before him in awe
of his status as a living God on
Aristotle's recommendation his nephew
calles the news had been appointed as an
office historian of Alexander's Asiatic
expedition callousness was concerned
about the Kings out of control ego and
somewhat foolishly let his concerns be
known and well this led to his execution
then in 323 BC the 32 year old Alexander
he suddenly died soon thereafter the pro
Macedonian governments it was forcibly
removed the Athenians were now back in
control and a backlash was unleashed
against the Macedonians
[Music]
Aristotle is the leading Macedonian
intellect and supporter of Alexander was
a prime target of the new regime he was
formally charged with in piety or not
believing in the gods of the state this
was the same charge that had been
leveled at Socrates and had led to his
conviction and his execution stating
that he refused to allow Athens to sin
against philosophy twice Aristotle
decided not to stay and defend himself
he fled the city and headed for the
island of Euboea where his mother's
estate was located he died on the island
in 323 BC of natural causes
it was 62 years of age now normally this
is where a biographical video would ends
but there is much more about Aristotle
to come but first I do want to thank
today's sponsor brilliance and I know
ads in the middle of a video they aren't
great but sponsors like brilliant do
make these longer videos possible
brilliant or a science learning platform
that allow you to learn through active
learning which summed up is basically
the opposite of that feeling of reading
a complex paragraph about some principle
and then just having absolutely no clue
about what they were going on about you
know even though you've read it 10 times
still got no idea what's happening and
brilliant don't just cover the basics
although they totally cover those as
well they go all the way through to
really complex things like advanced
statistics brilliant makes even complex
statistical concepts very easy to
understand they give me something super
short to read it's easy and then you
immediately apply what you just read to
a problem and rinse and repeat and boom
suddenly you understand stuff that you
didn't really think you'd ever be able
to understand I've used brilliant to do
just this it's pretty amazing how
quickly you grasp such a complex
subjects you can support by graphics by
going to brilliant org /by graphics and
now let's get back to Aristotle
Aristotle had died as an enemy of the
state and so memory of him he was
discouraged however his student and
friend Theophrastus kepts is writing
secretly hidden while also taking the
reins of the Lyceum the works of
Aristotle did not see the light of day
until the beginning of the first century
BCE when they became appreciated
throughout the Roman world after the
fall of Rome Aristotle became familiar
to the Islamic world as well where many
thinkers if the time came to appreciate
his logical and deductive methodology in
fact it was largely because of his
popularity in the Byzantium world that
Aristotle's teachings were able to
survive the dark ages it was during the
13th century CE that Aristotle was
reintroduced to the West this was
achieved primarily through the work of
Thomas Aquinas who attempted to
amalgamate religious beliefs with
science and philosophy Aquinas
incorporated Aristotle's assertion that
a stationary earth lies at the center of
the universe as a fundamental tenet of
Catholicism during the Renaissance and
Reformation years a succession of
religious reformers and scientists began
to question some Aristotle and beliefs
that had been absorbed into the Catholic
Church one of them was the Italian
astronomer Galileo Galilei who presented
observational proof that the earth
orbited the Sun it's ironic that while
Aristotle would undoubtedly have
embraced this new observation the
Catholic Church Fathers made Galileo
appear before the Inquisition and recant
his assertion English physicist William
Harvey later discovered that internal
organs don't work the way that Aristotle
had stated another of Aristotle's views
that was disproved was that decay only
happens on the earth while the heavens
never change 19th century astronomers
Lord Kelvin challenged this notion with
the concept of entropy which states that
all matter whether earthly or heavenly
will eventually decay Aristotle also
taught that planets and stars are all
encased in crystalline spheres each one
nested inside the next with the earth
being the innermost sphere by the 18th
century the contradictory idea that the
planets hang on a void was gaining
acceptance
[Music]
Aristotle wrote some 10 million words in
order to preserve his thoughts
unfortunately the majority of them have
not survived the passing of the years
the manuscripts were uncovered in the
1st century BCE when they were edited by
a man named Andronicus the works that we
have today are derived from Andronicus
as edited versions and so we're not
directly prepared for publication by
Aristotle today we are able to read
about a million of Aristotle's writings
which represents some 20% of his total
work as a result of the paucity of
writings that we have we are only able
to see a shadow of the brilliance of
Aristotle the quality of the prose which
has been lost to us was hinted at by
Roman statesman Cicero who went glaring
Aristotle's writings to those of Plato
declared if Plato's prose was silver
Aristotle's was a flowing river of gold
the works of Aristotle that have
survived are grouped into four
categories first is the organ on which
quantify a set of logical principles to
follow when conducting an investigation
then comes the theoretical consisting of
a range of treatises on the natural
world the practical category focuses on
achieving excellence within the
individual the family and in society
finally the rhetoric writing is collect
together Aristotle's surviving political
and philosophical speeches
[Music]
Aristotle divided the sciences into
three categories the productive the
practical and the theoretical productive
sciences income for such things as
building an architecture but also
battlefield strategy and courtroom
tactics there's also practical sciences
which cover ethics and guided behavior
the theoretical sciences which included
mathematics and physics involved the
quest for knowledge and understanding as
their own end result the scope of
Aristotle's scientific research it was
staggering his writings feature minut
descriptions of more than 500 species
some of the features that he observed
were not verified until the invention of
the microscope thousands of years later
his detailed observations included the
anatomy diet habitat and reproductive
system of the fish insects and animals
that he observed while on the island of
Lesvos a trademark of Aristotle's
thinking was that evidence was the
ultimate arbiter of truth regardless of
what theories you may hold if
observation proved them wrong then you
must have the humility to discard them
and go with the evidence despite being
charged with in piety Aristotle he did
believe in God however his God did not
create nor control the universe but
could affect it
he viewed God as the ultimate abstract
reason and considered that the highest
level of attainment for a human is to as
closely emulate God's ability to reason
abstractly as possible so the closer a
person could get to this heightened
ability to reason the closer they would
be to God himself
Aristotle's greatest contribution to
mankind was that he provided a
methodology by which to find solutions
to problems rather than providing these
solutions themselves when he did come to
conclusions he was careful to qualify it
by stating that the conclusion was based
upon the evidence available at the time
if new evidence was to come to light
that proved his conclusions wrong then
he would discard them however during the
period known as the Christian middle
ages between 476 and 1453 C II
Aristotle's methodology was cast aside
and the focus went squarely on his
conclusions which contrary to his wishes
were accepted without question so rather
than observing nature to find the
answers they simply accepted what eros
hood written on the subject
Plato and Aristotle ended up with very
different philosophical approaches plato
was the ultimate idealist believing that
the world around us is merely a
collection of ideas on the other hand
Aristotle was a realist who believed
that the only reality was the physical
world which we inhabit each man would
provide a work of political philosophy
in plato's case he was entitled the
Republic while Aristotle called his the
politic Plato's work was focused on
achieving the ideal state he believed
that one way to achieve this was through
the eradication of private property the
family and gender roles by doing away
with the societal norms Plato was hoping
to transcend human selfishness in order
to achieve social unity Aristotle
however rejected the end goal of Plato's
ideal state he contended that
selfishness is a part of human nature
his idea was to design a government that
acknowledged human selfishness and put
in place checks and balances to mitigate
it he pointed out the impracticality of
Plato's views asking such questions as
who would look after the children if
they weren't part of a family he further
contended that human selfishness is one
of the driving forces the results in
achievement
Aristotle devised a working government
that he referred to as polity in it
there was balance between the rich and
the poor with neither one dominating the
other and people were forced to work
together for the overall good of society
while retaining their property rights
one of the hallmarks of Aristotle's
method of argument was logical
developments where each point builds
upon the last this was very different to
Plato who would jump all over the place
with his ideas in contrast Aristotle
emphasized that need for mental
discipline by which those engaged in
debate would stay focused on the topic
at hands
Plato was mainly concerned with the
accumulation of knowledge he believed
that ideas were subjective and could be
influenced by personal views Aristotle
on the other hand was focused on
observation and the examination of what
is real
he was an objective thinker who did not
allow place for emotion or personal
opinion Plato was an idealist he
believed for example that knowing good
was enough for a person to do God
Aristotle however argued that knowing
good was not good enough the person had
to practice being good to benefit
himself as well as society Plato also
believe that every concept had an ideal
form whereas Aristotle was
of a view that every conception needed
to be studied on an individual level in
order to understand it
Plato was of the view that reasoning and
thought experiments were sufficient to
prove matters whereas Aristotle relied
upon direct experience as a results of
their differing approaches the
scientific contributions of Aristotle
were much greater than those of his
teacher Plato the latter's teachings
were predominantly theoretical lacking
practicality whereas Aristotle he's left
us with the scientific method which is
grounded in practical observation so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did do give us a
thumbs up below and please don't forget
to subscribe if you want to see more
biographic Swee put out several videos
just like this so hit that subscribe
button and hit that notification bell if
you actually want to find out when we
put our videos youtube doesn't work how
it used to and if you want to see
something else by us we've got some
videos from the archive linked you on
the screen and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]